[Musique]
bonsoir nouveau numéro de municipal 2014
municipal 2014 numéro 8 votre
rendez-vous politique pour tout savoir
du prochain scrutin en mars dans les
Yvelines je recevrai dans un instant
François deignier ma socialiste de Guill
en cour qui va briguer un nouveau mandat
Raymond Besco conseiller municipal la
manilamo viendra également sur ce
plateau nous verrons s'il entend ou non
mener une candidature Front de Gauche en
mars prochain aussi il figurera sur la
liste socialiste du ma sortant nous
évoquons aussi la situation à morpa avec
SEP candidatures à ce jour plus ou moins
déclaré premier invité de municipal 2014
François deignier bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau maire de Guille
en cours depuis 2002 suite à la
démission de Roland nado élu au sein du
conseil municipal depuis
1989 2008 c'était le premier scrutin sur
votre nom vous avez totalisé 73 % des
suffrages au premier tour candidat une
nouvelle fois candidat serein est-ce que
vous êtes serein aujourd'hui avant
d'être candidat je suis déjà ma avec
cette responsabilité euh d'aller
jusqu'au terme du mandat et en même
temps je serai candidat avec une équipe
et une équipe sereine oui avec du
travail devant nous mais la sérénité
mais comment vous abordez cette
candidature cette nouvelle campagne
lorsqu l'élection précédente on a été
élu dès le premier tour 73 %. vous savez
une élection ne ressemble jamais à une
autre euh je crois que ce qui est
important c'est de créer une dynamique
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec mon
équipe et en perspective de mars 2014 h
nous invitons les les habitants de
guillencour l'ensemble des habitants qui
se reconnaissent dans le le projet de
ville nous les invitons à à venir
participer au bilan au bilan de ces 6
années et également à la préparation du
mandat prochain c'est-à-dire les
perspectives en tout cas l'UMP a décidé
de se montrer plus agressive cette année
avec la candidature déjà déclarée de
Ladislas scoura c'est un Guillon
courtois il a 25 ans é lève avocat au
barreau de Paris quelle réaction vous
avez sur ce choix de l'UMP de rajunir sa
tête de liste sur en cours je ne sais
pas s'ils avaient vraiment le choix en
tout cas je ne connais pas monsieur
scura ça va être l'occasion de le
découvrir et vous savez un rendez-vous
démocratique c'est pour que les
habitants aient le choix donc je pense
qu'il y aura aussi d'autres candidats il
fait de sa jeunesse sa force le
précédent résultat 2008 ne lui fait
d'ailleurs pas peur on va l'écouter nous
développer son projet notamment les SCOR
de 2008 ne me font absolument pas peur
moi je pense que on peut vraiment faire
quelque chose euh et je pense que dès
2014 va y avoir il va y avoir de très
très bons scores et j'en suis persuadé
parce que je pense que les Guill en
courtois ont besoin de changement ils
ont besoin de voir de nouvelles têtes de
voir des jeunes de voir de de nouveaux
responsables politiques donc rien que
sur ça je pense que c'est important vous
savez l'équipe actuelle est là depuis
plusieurs décennies avec une équipe
vieillissante on est en train de
travailler sur de de belles thématiques
notamment sur la sécurité je pense que
le la première chose qu'une ville doit
garantir c'est la sécurité des biens et
des personnes donc ça c'est très très
important euh je pense aussi que
il y a quelque chose à faire sur
l'activité économique sur guencour il y
a un très grand paradoxe à guencour on
veut faire venir des sociétés sur sur
guencour on connait par Mercedes va
arriver sur notre territoire mais
derrière à guencour on est à 52 % de
logements sociaux on peut pas faire
amener les employés de de Mercedes ici
leur dire bah voilà on a plein de
logements sociaux à vous proposer ça
c'est quelque chose qui aujourd'hui à
guencour n'est pas cohérent donc
également on va on va on va s'attaquer
sur ce point-l et puis je pense que le
point crucial également c'est la
question la démocratie locale je crois
que la mairie a pris trop ses aises ici
il nous reste encore un petit peu temps
il nous reste encore 6 mois pour pour je
dirais ficeler tout ça mais on est prêt
on est prêt pour 2014 votre réaction
François de Liger à cette notion
d'équipe vieillissante cette déclaration
de Ladislas coura je je je laisse la
déclaration à son auteur moi ce que ce
que je remarque c'est que ce qui compte
c'est la dynamique humaine et je peux
vous assurer qu'avec mon équipe on a
cette dynamique humaine et ce que je
voudrais dire aussi c'est que sent un
véritable décalage avec ce qui est Guill
en cour il y a une sorte de découverte
de Guill en cour mais qui est très
étonnante le développement économique
vous savez comme moi que évidemment
c'est un des atouts de Guill encour au
même titre que la mixité sociale lui
parlait de ville pas adapté pour ses
entreprises de de haut niveau qui
embauche des des salariés cadres cadres
supérieurs alors que la Ville propose 52
% de logements sociaux l'habitat n'est
pas en relation avec les entreprises
qu'on souhait faire venir ou qui
viennent s'installer sur le territoire
et pourtant et pourtant le Crédit
Agricole a prévu une extension
pour plus de 1000 nouveaux
collaborateurs et pourtant malakov mic a
choisi de rester à Guill encour et vous
savez comme moi également que le
Technocentre Renault va accueillir des
nouveaux employés il aura 1200 emplois
supplémentaires00 emplois
supplémentaires bon je crois que les
chiffres parlent ce sera des des emplois
des salariés qui viennent de l'unité de
production de r mal maison qui viendront
sur gu en cour ce qui fait tout de même
du logement un enjeu aussi pour
développer l'habitation l'habitat sur la
ville de Guy enc est-ce que ça fera
partie de vos axes de C
bien sûr je parlais de des atouts de
Guill en cours le développement
économique c'est important pour l'emploi
c'est important pour les ressources de
la ville il y a également les les grands
équilibres et la mixité sociale en fait
partie vous savez qu'un Guy en courtois
puisse faire son parcours résidentiel à
Guill encour ça semble très très
important quand je parle de parcours
résidentiel c'est on a besoin à certains
moments de la vie d'être en en locatif
aidé à d'autres moment il faut pouvoir
favoriser l'accession à la propriété et
notamment la propriété aidée ça fait
partie des atouts de la ville pour
continuer à vous faire réagir sur les
points de programme qui sont développés
par votre opposant sur le prochain
scrutin le candidat de Ladislas scoura
pour l'UMP udi il évoque aussi la la
question de la sécurité est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui la sécurité est assurée
aux concitoyens aux habitants de
Guyancourt guyan courtoise bien sûr et
nous avions est-ce que pendant l'été il
y a eu des débordements suite à aux
événements qui se sont produits sur
traap ça a aussi touché en partie la
ville de guyancour hein bien bien sûr et
avec une d'ailleurs médiatisation qui
était euh étonnante puisque finalement
beaucoup de gens euh vivants dans les
différents quartiers de guyencour nous
ont a dit être surpris parce qu'il
pouvait entendre au niveau de la presse
nationale il faut pas cacher un
débordement quand il a lieu vous savez
la sécurité c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement sérieux il faut que la
police nationale puisse euh faire son
travail et c'est un travail de
sécurisation avec le droit régalien
évidemment et puis que la police
municipale intervienne en complément
c'est ce qu'elle fait on a une police
municipale à Guill encour qui est très
proche des administrés à la fois avec
les points écoles les cavaliers verts
euh les l'enlèvement des épaves le
contact avec les habitants l'écoute et
la disponibilité pour assurer cet autre
aspect de la sécurité qui est la
tranquillité des habitants et dans
certains quartiers justement des
habitants se plaignaient d'un manque de
tranquillité aussi sur la ville de
Guille en cours est-ce que ces problèmes
ont été résolus c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'aborde aussi cet aspect là il
fait partie de ce que doivent faire en
complémentarité la police nationale et
la police municipale bien sûr l'enjeu de
ces élections municipales on a eu
l'occasion déjà d'en parler c'est aussi
ces élections au Conseil Communautaire
de renavant les électeurs vont désigner
aussi leurs élus au prochain conseil
d'agglomération de de 550 ans en
niveline et puis il y aura une part
aussi proportionnelle on l'avait évoqué
le il y a 15 jours sur ce plateau avec
le président de l'agglomération Robert
Cadalbert qui sera d'ailleurs sur votre
liste socialiste aux prochaines
élections municipales vous regardez avec
attention le les résultats probables des
oppositions dans chacune des communes
dans votre commune aussi alors la
première chose qu'on peut dire c'est que
c'est une nouveauté avec ces fléchages
entre guillemets il va falloir
d'ailleurs donner des explications par
que c'est nouveau pour les électeurs
également mais je voudrais d'abord
rappeler que vous savez ce que sera la
majorité de la communauté
d'agglomération va d'abord dépendre des
résultats des élections municipales dans
les SEP communes ça serait donc prendre
les choses à l'envers que de parler des
de la future majorité de l'agglomération
elle proviendra des résultats des
élections au municipal c'est la raison
pour laquelle il est prématuré de la
même manière que vous voyez je suis pour
la première fois à vous dire j'invite
les habitants à participer
au bilan pour qu'il puissent
s'approprier le bilan évidemment les
élus l'ont travaillé je les invite aussi
à parler de la définition et des
perspectives pour le mandat prochain
donc la liste viendra en son temps cha
j'allais dire chaque chose en son temps
en tout cas ce sera une liste d'union ou
pas autour de la gauche alors vous savez
on est dans une situation où aguille en
cour il y a une liste déjà de
rassemblement et le rassemblement a bien
fonctionné pendant les 6 ans et donc
c'est un bilan qu'on portera
collectivement avec les autres
sensibilités une liste de rassemblement
de gauche avec les différentes
sensibilités qui peuvent aller fièrement
devant les électeurs on aura du
renouvellement mais du renouvellement au
sens où certains passeront le témoins
comme on l'avait fait en 2008 ce qui
fait que d'ailleurs il est abérant de
dire qu'on est vieillissant on est à peu
près comme tout le monde c'estàd qu'on
vieillit d'un an par anné d' an par anné
et en même temps il y a toujours du
renouvellement au niveau de l'équipe ça
c'est important il faut qu'on ait la la
diversité des quartiers la diversité des
âges la diversité diversité des couleurs
politiqu également au niveau
rassemblement bien s
on est déjà dans ce casill encour et
donc la démarche que je veux annoncer
aujourd'hui celle de travailler avec
l'iguill en courtoi on le fera avec les
différentes sensibilités rassemblées et
puis le moment viendra de présenter une
liste mais faisons les choses dans
l'ordre d'abord le bilan et vous avez
vous savez que c'est un bilan qui est
qui est très fort j'évoqué des atouts de
Guill en cours le bilan c'est l'ensemble
des engagements pris en 2008 devant
l'aiguille en courtois et bien plus
encore parce que dans bien des domaines
nous sommes adaptés à l'évolution de la
ville et nous avons apporté j'allais
dire au-delà des engagements pris en
2008 et ce sont des engagements pris par
une équipe rassemblée votre liste sera
connue quand dévoilé quand ah ben vous
savez en en en général c'est c'est
vraiment dans la dernière ligne droite
je le redis on va d'abord faire ce
travail avec l'aiguillon courtois en
même temps j'ai la responsabilité avec
mon équipe d'assurer les services
publics de qualité et de faire en sorte
que la ville fonctionne régulièrement
quotidiennement pour répondre aux
besoins des habitants et c'est donc
vraiment dans la période de dernière
ligne droite et dans la campagne
officielle qu'on présentera la liste et
sans surprise je peux déjà vous dire ça
sera une liste avec une volonté de
rassemblement très fort à l'image de ce
que ce qu'on a déjà fait la fois
précédente et avec une volonté de
renouvellement c'est bien normal on
l'avait déjà fait la dernière fois on va
évoquer tout à l'heure dans cette
édition de de municipale 2014 la
situation à morpa où il y a se candidats
plus ou moins déclarés qui souhaite
devenir maire sur cette sur cette
commune du côté des socialistes ismaill
avan votre votre collègue au Conseil
Général puisqu'il est représentant du
canton de morpa sollicite l'investiture
face à Hervé Miclot qui lui est
conseiller municipal de la majorité
sortante vous avez un favori entre les
deux B je je vais pas euh rentrer plus
que cela dans les questions liées à
morpa ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
effectivement je connais bien ismaela
Vann qui est mon collègue au conseil
général nous travaillons dans le même
groupe avec le même sérieux et je je
connais ces qualités ce qui n'enlève
rien aux autres pour autant on peut on
déduire que vous soutenez plutôt la
candidature d'Ismaël avan malgré tout
vous venez de le dire une dernière
question on va parler du du cumul des
mandats il y a un projet de loi qui sera
présenté une nouvelle fois à l'Assemblée
pour une nouvelle lecture je vous pose
cette question parce que l'Express a
fait à palmarès il y a tout juste un
mois des différents élus 1573 élus et le
cumul des mandats en question vous êtes
classé 748e sur 1573 élu Jean-Paul
Huchon est le premier des socié iste à
la 446e place voilà pour les les
précisions vous êtes vous êtes maire
vous êtes vice-président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 50 ans
Yveline conseiller général des des
ivlines également quel regard vous
portez sur cette question du cumul des
mandats parce que ça divise la classe
politique he que ce soit à gauche à
droite oui mais je je je crois que nous
devons à nos concitoyens quelques
explications je suis pour ma part
totalement en accord avec l'idée qu'il
faut absolument limiter les mandats et
notamment les exécutifs mais vous savez
quand on est maire on est vous l'avez
dit tout tout à l'heure d'ailleurs on
est forcément à la communauté
d'agglomération c'est pas un cumul ça
fait partie de son travail d'élu local
et je suis maire et conseiller général
et je représente une partie de 50 ans au
nieline au conseil général sans être
dans l'exécutif ce que je veux souligner
c'est que je suis contre le fait d'avoir
deux exécutifs parce que c'est trop
lourd vous savez mes responsabilités de
maire je l'ai fait enfin je les assume
entièrement ça demande énormément de
temps et quand on est à l'agglomération
ou au conseil général c'est pour pour
porter les besoins du territoire c'est
pour travailler dans l'intérêt des
habitants et les représenter par contre
être à deux exécutifs ça n'a jamais été
ma volonté merci François deignier maire
de guyancour socialiste candidat à un
nouveau mandat en mars prochain et vous
reviendrez sur ce plateau nous dévoiler
votre liste cette fois-ci merci à vousci
AMPA donc je vous le disais cette
situation qui reste pour le moins
compliquée nous en avons parlé sur cette
antenne si vous suivez notre journal
quotidien pas moins de se candidats
potentiels et des échanges qui se
tendent alors que la campagne débute à
peine dernière tenstion date lors du
conseil municipal du mois de septembre
voici un petit rappel qui sera le
prochain maire de morpa 7 ils sont
aujourd'hui 7 à convoiter le poste
occupé par George Mougeot depuis 4
mandats et ils se sont retrouvés jeudi
soir lors du conseil municipal Michel
Chapa 2e adjoint aux finances divers
gauche soutenu officiellement par le
maire sortant Michel e également adjoint
au sport celui-ci qui se présentera sur
une liste indépendante associative Hervé
mcllot adjoint socialiste à la culture
qui sollicite l'investiture d'ailleurs
de sa sa formation tout comme ismaï avan
conseiller général PS du canton de
morpin sans oublier Jean sindouhi dans
l'opposition écologiste pierre le
guerinel premier adjoint de la majorité
représentant de l'UDI et qui sollicite
le soutien de l'UMP ainsi que Grégory
garestier qui siégeit pour la première
fois en remplacement d'un conseiller
deopposition démissionnaire lui aussi
envisage l'investiture de l'UMP en mars
en tant que chef de fil du parti sur
cette ville et entre les deux hommes le
temps se durcit et je rappelle quand
même que Monsieur le guerinel a été
investi par le PS 2008 et que maintenant
il essaie de repartir à droite un coup à
gauche un coup à droite moi j'appelle ça
un opni un objet politique non identifié
on ne sait pas trop ce qu'il veut faire
on ne sait pas trop où il est donc qu'il
règle ses problèmes avec l'UDI et il
n'aura pas fallu attendre longtemps pour
que la tension monte encore d'un cran en
salle du conseil après l'annonce par
Pierre Le Guérinel de sa démission de la
majorité afin de préparer sa campagne
son opposant n'a pas fait dans la
demi-mesure en parlant de mascarade il a
été en réalité désigné comme tête de fil
euh même s'il a dit longtemps qu'il
était investi je crois qu'il y a eu un
rappel à l'ordre de la part de la
présidente de la Fédération pour dire
que ça n'était pas ça c'est parfaitement
clair monsieur garessier n'a pas
l'investiture vous voulez un scoop et
bien j'aurai comme colistière ma numéro
2 de liste sera celle qui la dernière
fois avait monté une liste à côté de la
mienne ce sera Nicole malacin et l'UMP
devrait trancher avant la fin de l'année
et choisir son représentant en mars du
côté des socialistes la scène a été
observée avec attention par Ismail avane
et Hervé miklot eux aussi en concurrence
donc et qui attendent que les militants
fassent leur choix le 10 octobre toute
ambition est légitime je le dis comme je
l'ai dit et comme la section le sait je
pense qu'il a un poste de conseill
général à assumer qu'il faut le
reprendre en 2015 et je pense que une
complémentarité est plus significative
pour le PS qu'une concurrence interne
une fois les investitures officialisées
de part et d'autre restera ensuite au
candidats à composer avec les listes
indépendantes mais aussi dissidentes
Michel chaapa élu depuis 1989 le seul à
avoir reçu le soutien officiel du maire
se dit serein il y en a qui choisissent
une politique de rupture un programme de
rupture ils le disent ben moi ça sera
tout le contraire ça sera une politique
de continuité un programme deuité bien
entendu qui évoluera qui présentera des
propositions nouvelles quand on décide
de se présenter c'est qu'il y a autour
de soi un certain nombre de personnes
qui vont dans le même sens qui poussent
en général qui poussent qui acceptent
qui coopèrent qui sont en plein accord
avec soi-même he on y va pas comme ça
tout seul alors effectivement il y a une
équipe assez fournie autour de moi prête
à assumer les responsabilités et
concernant la candidature de
l'investiture d'isma avan le socialiste
annonce que les militants si les
militants le choisissent lui aussi
entend réaliser une liste d'ouverture
au-delà de son parti peut-être un appel
du pied à certains membres de l'actuelle
majorité la ville est plutôt belle bien
gérée George Mougeot qui est maire
divivers gauche ancien
socialiste de la vie de tous fait du bon
travail je le dis aussi
je souhaite si je suis amené à monter
une liste avoir une liste la plus large
possible et qui aille au-delà du Parti
socialiste parce que c'est une élection
locale deè invité de ce numéro 2
municipal 2014 rond Besco bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau actuel
conseiller municipal délégué au
développement durable et au déplacement
début juillet le Parisien vous présenter
comme candidat du Front de Gauche en
mars prochain voici d'ailleurs l'article
dans lequel vous répondez aux
journalistes avec cette candidature on
se met en ordre de marche on va discuter
sur des bases claires pour être clair
justement êtes-vous candidat aux
prochaines élections municipales à
Manamo oui je serai
candidat au titre du collectif
AutreMonde et du groupe AutreMonde qui
existe depuis maintenant plus de 7 ans
sur
manilameau certains ont penser que je
voulais être tête de liste ce n'est pas
le mandat que l'on a pour l'instant
euh je serai chef de fil du groupe
AutreMonde dans le cadre des futures
élections municipature ça veut dire que
vous serez présent sur la liste
socialiste de Bertrand Ouillon sortant
ou serait présent sur une liste aux
élections municipal nous avons pas
forcément avec l'actuelle majorité je ne
sais pas encore nous sommes en
discussion avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires de gauche les socialistes
les Verts pour travailler à la fois sur
le pramme de notre prochain mandat mais
surtout sur le bilan des trois mandats
écoulés puisque c'est le 3ème mandat où
nous travaillons ensemble sur magam vous
laissez planer tout de même le doute sur
cette candidature parce que vous parlez
de chef de fil en général un chef de fil
se retrouve peut-être de listes sur une
ah pas spécialement non c'est pas la
lecture que nous en avons nous avons une
tradition à Manamo d'avoir un groupe
d'avoir plus de groupes dans la majorité
et ce qui n'empêche pas de travailler
ensemble depuis maintenant trois mandats
mais il y a finalement en général une
seule liste de gauche on verra c'est
notre volonté mais on y travaille ça
veut dire que tout le monde ne va pas
dans ce sens là où en sont les
discussions avec la
majorité je ne sais pas si vous avez des
informations tout je cherche à les avoir
c'est pour ça que je question nous
travaillons nous discutons dans une très
bonne
ambiance et surtout nous continuons à
appliquer notre programme jusqu'à la fin
du mandat aucun problème entre nous au
sein de la majorité on sait qu'au niveau
national en tout cas il y a des voix
Europe Écologie Les ver pour un
rochement avec le Front de Gauche la
gauche de la gauche eva jolie le
souhaite notamment elle proposera une
motion le 30 novembre prochain à quand
lors du congrès d'Europe Écologie Les
vert quel est votre avis il faut que le
Front de Gauche se rapproche d'Europe
Écologie Les vert est-ce que ces deux
partis doivent se rassembler dans
l'opposition je ne me prononcerai pas au
niveau national mais en tous les cas je
peux vous dire que les ver de les vers
de manilamo viennent d'adhérer au
collectif AutreMonde la semaine dernière
donc vous aimez vous aimeriez revoir la
même chose au niveau national peut-être
cette alliance là avir un all
supplémentaire essayer de travailler sur
Manil Amou voilà je je n'ai pas
d'ambition au niveau national et pas de
conseil à donner à ce niveau-là c'est
trop compliqué al après il y a des
responsables de parti aussi he Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Jean-Luc Mélenchon
co-président du Parti de Gauche pilier
avec le PCF du Front de gauche qui est
très critique vis-à-vis des socialistes
du gouvernement mais des socialistes en
général vous c'est pas le cas sur
manilamo vous n'êtes pas critique avec
le le mer socialiste j'aime bien
Jean-Luc il dit des choses extrêmement
justes sur la polique nationale et
exactement euh il dit des choses très
très justes au niveau national sur la
politique qui est menée par le
gouvernement et qui ne nous convient
absolument pas maintenant sur Manil amau
nous travaillons avec nos camarades
socialistes de très bonne manière depuis
fort longtemps on sait que l'UMP fait de
cette ville une priorité avec la
candidature d'oror berger qui a été
porté notamment par Valérie pcres qui la
soutient régulièrement est-ce que vous
n'avez pas peur d'une dispersion des
voix aussi à gauche s'il y avait
plusieurs listes à gauche je sais pas
pourquoi vous me parlez de plusieurs
listes en tous les cas en ce qui
concerne Ren n clair de votre côté si si
c'est très clair alors il a je vous ai
déjà répondu deux fois mais en ce qui
concerne berger elle est extrêmement
active on dira un petit peu le lapin du
racel mais elle a besoin de beaucoup de
soutien extérieur j'ai remarqué qu'elle
fait venir des des pointures c'est bon
c'est c'est peut-être drôle mais pour
l'instant elle a un programme qui est
vraiment extrêmement compliqué à suivre
et et à lire alors quand elle parle de
votre candidature elle évoque une
candidature fantôme afin de permettre au
fond de gauche au groupe autre monde de
mieux négocier des places sur une liste
commune et au Parti socialiste ensuite
de se poser en rassembleur le fantôme la
salue bien euh en tout entre la p du
racel et
fantômes non mais elle emploie des des
termes qui sont pas très très agréables
euh je préférerais qu'elle fasse des
propositions concrètes de manière à ce
qu'on puisse débattre en tous les cas en
ce qui nous concerne pour les élus du
groupe AutreMonde on continue à
travailler on tient les réunions avec
les habitants on continue à faire
avancer nos dossier donc tout va bien
sur quels sont les dossiers prioritaires
justement pour vous pour votre
candidature sur une liste à gauche de la
gauche avec la gauche on le verra dans
les prochains mois mais en tout cas qu
son intéressant sur le le contenu du
programme on est extrêmement attaché à
tout ce qui touche au au développement
social au au programme écologique tout
ce qui est on a mis en place pendant
tout ce mandat un certain nombre
de de de de nouvelles orientations dans
la matière et donc on entend bien
pouvoir les continuer dans le dans le
mandat suivant c'est long c'est beaucoup
trop long à mon avis à mettre en œuvre
on bute sur des problèmes de financement
comme toutes les communes euh sera les
solutions justement comment faire les
solutions c'est de refaire un mandat
supplémentaire et de pouvoir aller
jusqu'au bout de nos idées mais après il
manque des fonds aussi il manque des des
financements comment ramener des fonds
c'est juste un peu plus long à mettre en
œuvre voilà on prévoyait d' les
priorités sont pas forcément les B
2014 il y a pas les financements du
département ça sera plutôt 2016 et ben
il faudra le finir pendant le prochain
mandat très concrètement ça veut dire
qu'il faut aussi redéfinir des priorités
au sein de la mandature qui s'achève il
faut remettre les choses à
plat effectivement effectivement il y a
des il y a des choses à imaginer pour
l'avenir là on termine un mandat donc il
faut essayer de terminer ce qui est
engagé et puis justement on travaille
avec nos partenaires socialistes les
vers sur la définition du bien compris
vous discutez beaucoup en ce moment
entre Europe Écologie Les ver ou les
socialistes à manilamour on se voit les
élus on se voit tous les lundis soirs
tous les élus de la majorité depuis 15
ans donc on n pas de problème pour
discuter entre nous il y a eu un
changement par rapport aux précédentes
élections c'est le départ de Jacques
lolios en cours de de mandat quel regard
vous portez sur ce passage de de relais
ce passage de témoins qui s'est fait à
bertrandouillon s'est très bien passé de
manière très dynamique Bertrand Houillon
était bien préparé pour prendre le
relais il a une vision extrêmement
dynamique qui se
rapproche très très fortement des
orientations défendu par notre groupe il
y a pas de de problème làdessus donc on
pourrait vous retrouver éventuellement
sur cette liste alors ou lui sur la
nôutre ah donc vous seriez-êre de liste
je sais pas ah vous savez pas en
effectivement les choses sont d' clair
vous non c'est très clair on discute et
vous essayez de nous faire dire les
choses avant qu' bien savoir où sont les
discussions vous le saurez oh les
électeurs vous inquiétez pas les
électeurs de Manamo nous connaissent on
tient suffisamment de réunions publiqu
avec eux euh ils connaissent notre Fran
parler on fait pas dans la dentelle
quand on parle avec eux euh voilà
donc quand ça sera le moment venu vous
saurez qui est tê de liste et s'il y a
une liste d'union de la gauche sur
manilamour et nous verrons c'est ce
qu'on souhaite en tous les cas hein
c'est ce que vous souhaitez c'est le
message que vous avez passé en tout cas
ce soir même s'il reste encore des
discussions en cours on l'a bien compris
merci Ron Besco d'être venu sur ce
plateau c'est la fin de ce numéro de
municipal 2014 prochain rendez-vous
politique sur TV fil dans 15 jour le 15
octobre les programmes qui se
poursuivent sur TV fil bonne
[Musique]
soirée